sad breaking news overnight at least 53
people dead more than 100 injured after
a cargo truck crashed in southern mexico
this is a truck said to be carrying
migrants mostly from guatemala and
honduras fleeing crime and poverty there
in search of a better life somewhere
omar villafranca has that story
a horrific scene in southern mexico
about 100 miles from the guatemalan
border authorities say a cargo truck
with some 200 people inside tried to
make a sharp turn rolled over and
crashed into a pedestrian bridge
this man a migrant from guatemala was in
the truck when it crashed he says that
when the truck hit a curb the sheer
weight of everyone inside caused the
vehicle to tip over he says many on
board were migrants from guatemala and
honduras
a rescue worker says a survivor told him
the truck was speeding when it lost
control many are fleeing poverty in
central america worsened by back-to-back
hurricanes as cbs news reported from
guatemala earlier this year
back in april we spoke to this 19 year
old who said he made it all the way to
mexico city before he ran out of money
to pay smugglers the white house is
urging migrants to stay in their
homelands and just reinstated the remain
in mexico policy for asylum seekers but
critics say tougher immigration policies
are what force migrants to rely on
smugglers to make the journey to the u.s
putting their lives at risk for cbs
mornings i'm omar villafranca